i gotta get this ball in the green and i
love being on the water man
[Music]
i've been playing basketball my whole
life since i was four years old so then
when i decided to retire
i did a lot of this when you get a day
off you just want to enjoy your friends
your family
go to the beach at last get a little
cocktail
i can't stress enough that i do play a
lot of golf on my off day it's great to
get out there with my buddies pack a
cooler cut water and get out there and
play 18 holes
when i got into baseball i was at a
young age i grew up playing t-bar i grew
up playing all the sports
so i got into golf you know right after
i was drafted in 0-9
all the guys we love to go out there and
play it's one of those things we really
enjoy
doing getting time away getting a chance
to get away from what you normally do on
the on on the court or on the field is
crucial for a professional athlete
you want to have a balance you want to
be able to go out there and grind hard
for your job
you know your career what have you but
also get away from it so you can come
back to it with a fresh clear head
and perform your best see what off days
are important especially in the big
leagues you know when you play 162 games
in 183 days i think it is so
you know it's a nice way to relax it's a
nice way to you know take your mind off
not having to worry about hitting a
slider that day
can you see those shots on the green
those are all darts
put that in there i've always wanted to
be in nature
going jet skiing going on boats stuff
like that i come out on the water man
got to get out in the water go on the
beach get a little tan
i'm a little pale right now but check me
out in about a month i'm gonna be real
nice bronze you feel me
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's a real birdie it was real that
was the first take
heads up
damn miami on jet skis never a bad day